es útil pretender que todos los
materiales en el universo pueden
clasificarse como aislantes o
conductores aislantes eléctricos o
conductores eléctricos aunque esto no es
cierto existen también los
semiconductores y los superconductores
así como otros materiales eléctricos
exóticos pero para la mayoría de los
problemas y exámenes de los cursos de
introducción a la física normalmente se
supone que todos los materiales son o
aislantes o conductores material
aislante eléctrico o material conductor
eléctrico y antes de hablar de las
diferencias de estos materiales que aquí
tenemos dos un cilindro aislante y un
cilindro conductor antes de hablar de
las diferencias vamos a mencionar una
cosa que tienen en común tanto el
material aislante como el material
conductor tienen una cantidad enorme de
átomos y moléculas y estos átomos no
importa si son del material aislante o
del conductor van a tener en el centro
carga positiva aquí en el núcleo y una
carga negativa que va a estar generada
por varios electrones que se encuentran
alrededor del núcleo y otra cosa en
común que tienen los conductores y los
aislantes es que el núcleo que tiene
carga positiva no se puede mover puede
vibrar quizás un poquito pero no va a
moverse del lugar estas mini vibraciones
podrían darse por cuestiones térmicas
pero no pueden moverse libremente a
través del material esto aplica tanto
para el aislante como para el conductor
siempre y cuando sean sólidos lo que no
aplica si es que estos son fluidos en el
caso de que sean fluidos se van a poder
mover libremente pero en el caso de
materiales sólidos la carga positiva del
núcleo de cada átomo se encuentra fija
lo único que podría moverse son los
electrones con carga negativa y aquí hay
una diferencia los electrones que se
encuentran en los átomos del conductor
en moverse más o menos libremente puede
moverse sin casi resistencia en cambio
los electrones en el aislante no se
pueden casi mover esto no tiene los
niveles de energía ni las bandas que
hagan posible que estos electrones se
muevan libremente así que para el
material aislante también se encuentran
más o menos fijos básicamente en los
aislantes todo se encuentra fijo estos
electrones podrían moverse y saltar
dentro de su propio átomo o quizás entre
átomos vecinos pero no pueden estar
saltando y moviéndose libremente por
todo el material y en los conductores
los electrones si pueden estar
moviéndose libremente por todo el
material esta es la diferencia principal
ahora los electrones no van a estar
moviéndose así por si solos necesitan
algo que los invite a moverse en el
material si conectaremos esto a una
batería o lo pasaremos cerca de algún
campo eléctrico o tuviera cerca alguna
fuerza eléctrica
en este caso los electrones en el
conductor van a comenzar a migrar por
todo el material pero en un aislante los
electrones están fijos y esto nos hace
pensar que a lo mejor para las
interacciones eléctricas solo nos
interesan los conductores y los
aislantes nos van a interesar justamente
para evitar estas interacciones
eléctricas pero esto no es del todo
cierto si yo pongo un aislante en una
batería o lo acercó algún campo o fuerza
eléctrica si bien los electrones no van
a estar saltando o van a estar
moviéndose en el material si puedo tener
que el núcleo y sus electrones se
desplacen un poquito por ejemplo aquí el
núcleo positivo puede desplazarse un
poquito así y la carga negativa de
desplazarse de este otro lado de manera
que me queda un átomo que digamos tiene
un lado un poco más negativo y este lado
del átomo estaría más positivo y aunque
los electrones no se mueven ahora como
tengo esta configuración en donde la
parte positiva está desplazada a un lado
y la negativa está un poquito del otro
lado este material si yo logro que todos
los átomos tengan esta configuración
podemos crear un efecto eléctrico
general y podrá interactuar con otras
cargas cercanas y ejercer fuerzas sobre
ellas así que aún cuando las cargas no
pueden flotar en el aislante pueden
interactuar eléctricamente ahora veamos
qué sucede si le agrego cargas extra al
aislante y al conductor aquí comenzamos
con la misma cantidad de partículas
positivas que de partículas negativas y
eso se cumple tanto para el aislante
como para el conductor pero qué sucede
si agrego cargas extras si agregamos
cargas negativas extras por aquí que va
a suceder si tratamos de dibujarlas con
todo y los átomos va a verse un poco
saturada a la pantalla y ya que éstas se
cancelan mutuamente tienen una carga
promedio así que vamos a suponer que
estos se encuentran aquí pero se
cancelan mutuamente y ahora voy a
dibujar solo
y las cargas extra si yo agrego cargas
negativas extra a este aislante que voy
a tener pongo cargas negativas por aquí
por acá
por allá que va a pasar bueno nosotros
sabemos que estas cargas negativas no se
pueden estar moviendo libremente aquí
así que puedo llenar este aislante con
las cargas negativas extra si es que así
lo quiero o puedo hacer que se acumulen
en un solo lado y allí se mantendrían el
punto es que donde yo ponga las cargas
extra ahí se van a quedar pero qué va a
suceder en un conductor si yo trato de
poner una carga negativa aquí y otra
carga negativa por acá estas no tienen
por qué quedarse en donde las puse
cuando están en un conductor y si
ponemos cargas negativas cercanas no van
a querer quedarse ahí ya que las cargas
iguales se repelen así que qué va a
suceder pues esta carga negativa va a
querer alejarse todo lo que pueda y esa
otra carga también querrá alejarse lo
más que se pueda
aunque claro la carga negativa no puede
saltar fuera del conductor para hacer
esto necesitaría de más energía pero si
puede llegar al límite al borde y esto
es lo que hacen las cargas y esto es lo
que sucede en los conductores si
agregamos cargas extras éstas se van a
acumular en el exterior ya sea que
agreguemos cargas negativas o cargas
positivas siempre se van a distribuir en
la parte exterior siempre se van a mover
hacia el borde por lo que solo podremos
agregar cargas extra en la parte
exterior del material ya que si las
pusiéramos adentro las cargas solitas se
van a mover hacia afuera y les comenté
que esto se cumple tanto para cargas
positivas como negativas y ustedes se
pueden preguntar bueno cómo es que
agrego cargas positivas bueno esto se
logra quitando cargas negativas
si comenzamos con un material que tiene
la misma cantidad de cargas negativas y
positivas y quitamos una carga negativa
esencialmente es como agregar una carga
positiva pero de igual manera la carga
neta ya sea positiva o negativa va a
recibir en la parte exterior del
conductor ya que las cargas tratan de
alejarse mutuamente entre sí lo más
lejos posible y cuáles materiales
físicos se comportan así qué materiales
son aislantes pues los materiales como
el vidrio la madera
estos son aislantes igual la mayor parte
de los plásticos también son aislantes
todos estos materiales muestran este
comportamiento en donde podemos agregar
cargas y éstas se van a quedar fijas en
donde las coloquemos las cargas no se
pueden mover libremente en este material
podemos poner incluso cargas en el
exterior del material y se van a quedar
ahí y ahora los materiales conductores
son metales como el oro o el cobre que
se usa bastante ya que es más barato que
el oro
la plata también funciona bastante bien
estos son materiales cuyas cargas flotan
o se mueven libremente en ellos y ahora
que sabemos cómo funcionan los aislantes
y los conductores veamos un ejemplo
digamos que tenemos dos cilindros
conductores están hechos de metal y uno
de ellos tiene una carga neta negativa
que se encuentra en la parte exterior de
este cilindro
ya que esto es lo que hace una carga
neta en un conductor pero este otro
cilindro conductor no tiene una carga
neta en él que es lo que sucede si yo
tomo este conductor lo acercó y hago que
toque al otro conductor yo creo que
ustedes se imaginan qué va a pasar las
cargas van a querer alejarse mutuamente
lo más lejos posible
por lo que al estar en contacto con este
otro conductor
algunas de las cargas de aquí se van a
alejar todavía más y van a pasar al otro
conductor otras se van a quedar en donde
estaban eso es lo que sucedería si ambos
conductores tienen la misma cantidad de
material tendríamos la misma cantidad en
ambos si éste otro conductor fuera un
poco más grande una mayor cantidad de
carga del primer conductor pasaría a
este otro más grande ya que de esta
manera se pueden alejar aún más aunque
algunas cargas se quedarían en este y
esta es una forma de cargar algo con
sólo tocarlo pero hay otra forma de
cargar los materiales y esto es más
inteligente podemos hacer algo llamado
carga por inducción
y esto qué significa bueno imaginen que
tomamos esto
lo acercamos aquí pero no tocamos al
otro cilindro
si solo lo acercó pero no hago que se
toquen qué va a pasar
bueno aquí de por sí tengo negativos
también tengo positivos pero los
negativos se pueden mover libremente si
quieren querrán moverse pues sí ya que
estos negativos se están acercando y los
que están aquí no quieren estar cerca de
ellos se quieren alejar lo más que se
pueda
así que una cantidad neta de cargas
negativas se van a ir hacia este lado se
van a ir todas de este lado ya que no
quieren estar cerca de las cargas
negativas que se encuentran aquí cerca
lo que nos deja una carga neta positiva
de este lado o lo que es lo mismo un
déficit de electrones en este lado por
lo que este lado termina cargado
positivamente y ustedes pueden pensar
bueno ok esto es extraño se han separado
las cargas va a pasar algo más pues sí
ya que ahora estas cargas positivas se
encuentran más cercanas a las que están
aquí las cargas negativas que están en
este otro cilindro
las cargas opuestas se van a atraer así
que estas cargas negativas de aquí van a
atraer a las cargas positivas de este
otro cilindro ya que las cargas
diferentes se atraen y las iguales se
repelen y estas cargas negativas van a
estar repeliendo a estas otras cargas
negativas de aquí estas fuerzas se
cancelan no de hecho no ya que mientras
más cercanas se encuentren las cargas
más fuerte será esta fuerza y esto
ocasionará que este cilindro sea atraído
por este otro y esto es genial ya que si
tomamos un cilindro que esté cargado y
lo acercamos no sé a una lata de
refresco si esta lata se encuentra
acostada en una mesa de manera que pueda
rodar si acercamos el cilindro cargado
la lata comenzará a rodar hacia este
cilindro lo cual es bastante genial y
deberían intentarlo si pueden pero esto
no es la carga por inducción la carga
por inducción es algo más imaginen que
conectamos este cilindro
qué es tierra bueno puede ser la tierra
lo que está en el suelo si tenemos una
tubería metálica y la enterramos en el
suelo nos puede servir o cualquier
material que nos permita tomar una
cantidad infinita de electrones o que
también podamos depositar una cantidad
infinita de electrones aquí ya este
material no le importe podría ser el
chasis de un auto que es de metal es una
buena tierra ya que puede proporcionar
una gran cantidad de electrones o
recibirlos o como ya habíamos mencionado
una tubería de metal enterrada en el
suelo un material al que no le importe
recibir o dar muchos electrones ahora
qué sucede si yo acerco ese cilindro
cargado a este otro conductor que
originalmente no tiene una carga neta
ahora sus electrones en lugar de
quedarse en un solo lado pueden decir
bueno pues yo me puedo ir de aquí ahora
sus electrones en lugar de quedarse de
este lado pueden decir saben que yo me
voy de aquí por lo que muchas de estas
cargas negativas se van a ir de aquí
pasa cuando esto sucede pues ahora
nuestro segundo cilindro ya no estará
sin carga ahora va a estar cargado va a
tener una carga neta y tampoco es que se
vayan todos los electrones alguno que
otros se quedara por ahí pero este
cilindro que originalmente no tenía
carga ahora va a estar cargado tendrá
una carga positiva por lo que cargue
este cilindro sin siquiera tocarlo ya
que deje que estos electrones negativos
se fueran y si soy lista puedo cortar
este cable de acá
antes de quitar el objeto que me indujo
la carga ahora quito esto de acá lo
pongo lejos y que hubieran hecho estos
electrones bueno hubieran dicho vaya qué
bueno que es ella se fue ahora puedo
regresar a donde estaba se van a sentir
atraídos a estas cargas positivas y van
a regresar dejando esto nuevamente sin
carga pero como corte el cable antes
pues ellos ya no pueden regresar estos
se quedan atorados aquí ya que no hay
forma de que puedan regresar porque
cortamos la línea y cuando cargamos algo
por completo sin tocarlo entonces
decimos que tuvimos una carga por
inducción
qué es un método muy sencillo de cargar
algo permítanme mostrarles otro ejemplo
que yo creo que todos hemos hecho alguna
vez tenemos aquí un globo y como lo
cargamos pues lo frotamos contra nuestro
cabello
el globo va a robar electrones de
nuestro cabello y ahora el globo va a
estar negativamente cargado que hacemos
con esto ustedes ya saben qué hacemos
con esto lo tomamos y lo ponemos cerca
de alguna pared o algún techo y si
tenemos suerte se va a quedar pegado ahí
lo que es genial cómo funciona esto
bueno recuerden que este es un material
aislante es plástico el techo también es
un material aislante aquí los electrones
no se van a transferir pero aún en un
material aislante el átomo puede
reorientarse o polarizarse al cambiar la
carga negativa de este átomo de un lado
y la carga positiva del mismo átomo del
otro lado por lo que un lado se vuelve
un poquito más positivo y esto ocasiona
una fuerza neta entre el techo y el
globo
que estos positivos se encuentran un
poquito más cercanos así que los
positivos van a estar atrayendo a los
negativos con un poquito más de fuerza
de lo que estos negativos están
repeliendo a los negativos del techo y
debido a que el techo atrae al globo y
el globo está atrayendo al techo con una
fuerza mayor de lo que las cargas
negativas están repeliendo a las cargas
negativas del techo el globo se va a
pegar y esto es debido a la propiedad de
los aislantes de polarizarse y ocasionar
una atracción eléctrica y es lo que
mencioné en un principio aún cuando sea
un aislante puede a veces interactuar
con algo eléctrico debido a que el átomo
puede moverse y polarizarse